downtime do you ever watch mindless - I
asked you this question before do you
ever watch mindless TV or YouTube videos
to decompress at the end of the day or
is that laziness justifying wasted time
yeah you know quite frankly I don't have
a lot of free time to do that even if I
was all fired up to watch a mindless
video on YouTube yeah so I guess I guess
not really if I'm gonna decompress
sometimes I mean sometimes my kids don't
want to watch something and I'll sit
there and watch all in watch an episode
of The Office good funny yeah yeah
that's a that makes sense
same same deal I think probably sir you
know of course I watched my whole life
I've oh that's a good one kind of
mindless like I didn't tell you this
I've watched zero I would if they put it
on screen right now I wouldn't even know
what it was
Lafe we went we were in the hotel gym
the other day ladies like check it out
points the TV I'm like what that's why I
even know what he's talking about
yeah yeah he took the picture yeah he
took a picture of it he said he felt
your presence yeah it's good yeah I
would've fired me up best workout in the
world right there well if I don't work
out bull shark